it's gotta be me because i said
obviously and i always say that so i'm
annoying god
i'm gonna find out how annoying i am in
this game oh my god
[Music]
to celebrate michelle obama coming to
the show i am going to play a game
called who said it me or michelle where
i read a random quote and i have to
guess
if michelle obama said it or myself
pretty self-explanatory here we go
i can make a grilled cheese sandwich
that's about all i can
do i can make a mean grilled cheese
sandwich that is probably me
because i that's one of the only things
i can make
so oh it's michelle oh um
i can make a mean grilled cheese
sandwich because it's and i can't make
many things
um i probably could i just don't want to
i think parenting changes you in the
best of ways it's made me stronger
but it's definitely hard it's the
hardest job out of all the jobs okay
here's how i know it's me
because i said all the jobs i say all
the jobs all the time
that it's me yes it's me um
parenting is hard it is rewarding but
it's really hard
you know you want to do well at it
you're shaping a human so
oh my good gosh this has to be me
oh my good gosh i say that all the time
oh my good gosh my dog just farted right
by me and i might die
that i remember henry that was
i got it was and it was silent but
deadly spd y'all i was like
all of a sudden i was eating it i was
like i was like it was bad
i love french fries i'm a big french
five fanatic this can't be me because
i'm not a huge french fry fanatic
so that's michelle i don't know why i
feel like i
i appear like i would be like she likes
french fries you know but like no
it's such a texas thing no i like them
when they're really you know what ones i
love
i do love the shoestring they're real
crispy
and they got some stuff like truffle on
them or something i don't know they come
out
sometimes it's and i'm like wait i could
get into that um but i don't like
regular french fries it's not it's
generally my thing i think
people can smell inauthenticity if
you're not comfortable in your own skin
that comes across it sounds so smart so
i probably
said it oh michelle definitely said that
i know no i would have guessed me it was
how she worded it
maybe she went to college and
and i didn't so i i actually
wholeheartedly believe that's why
trisha thought it was probably me it is
something i would say i maybe
wouldn't have said it um exactly like
that
like a poet like she did so it's fine
i was like well i guess i could be po
i'm a songwriter whatever
obviously twizzlers for the win it's
gotta be me because i said
obviously and i always say that so i'm
annoying god i'm gonna find out how
annoying i am in this game oh my god
twizzlers for the win every people be
talking about red vines i ain't got time
it's not the same that's controversial
it's not it's just someone's right and
someone's wrong
[Laughter]
um no i'm just kidding it is whatever
it's food and artist objective
oh why don't they make good rom-coms
anymore i feel like i would have said
that i mean i think i did
oh yes i did i did say that because they
don't we can't get
new ones i feel like everything is being
remade which is fine i like a lot of the
remakes but like
well let's bring some originality to the
to the table as well
and i come on they were so good and like
the
the 90s the 2000s like the early 2000s
because it's still the 2000s
moving on there is no boy
that is cute enough or interesting
enough to stop you from getting your
education
oh well that's totally michelle um but
totally true and i'm on board i feel
like why we're playing this game is we
have very similar
like interests and thoughts and ideals
so
um yeah and there is no boy cute enough
just let you know or girl whatever
you're into
i dream big i think you have to put it
out there i think you have to be
confident yourself this is totally me
right this is me yes okay this is me i
was like i always say i literally sign
my things dream big
so i was like wouldn't it be funny i
mean i guess i have missed some but like
i think that it's me and it's not like
if i said it so why don't i remember it
like
well that's where we're at i had so many
plans today and i think i shall do
none of them to me because
i say shall a lot i don't know why i
like to do that but i do
i shall not partake in that i say that a
lot yup
that's me i'm fancy michelle
i've just never cared what people think
it's more if i'm happy and i'm confident
and feeling good that's always been my
thing
that's me 100 yep that's me
because i think she would have said it
better she would have
said the same thing but would have come
across just far more eloquent
it's fine it's halloween dudes that's
totally good michelle
oh i say dude she said dudes
that's why i knew i loved her yeah
you're tricky
chrissy tricky chrissy i want sprinkles
that's me
yep sprinkles are so good like if you're
having
you know an ice cream that's smooth but
you get the little crunch with the
rainbow sprinkle don't give me those
chocolate sprinkles i want the rainbow
sprinkles is there another kind of
sprinkles just messed that up on the
show and you're literally
like i want sprinkles and you said that
oh okay okay i was like wait and then i
was
one of the kind of sprinkles you know
what
i'm gonna go take a nap but i am so
excited that you all maybe enjoyed this
and if you didn't
oh well it's done this is we did it
and michelle obama uses the word dudes i
think we've all learned something here
today
i shall be leaving you with this thank
you so much for hanging out with us
today this was
um did michelle say it or did i say it i
don't remember the name of the game who
said it me or michelle that's right
that's the name of the game um and i
hope you enjoyed it okay again because i
already said that but
cool bye yup i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever